Всім привіт Мене звати Курбанов Микита
Мені 15 років живу в містечку Городня
Чернігівська область займаюся танцями з
пти років це прям сенс мого життя кожен
рух - це прояв моєї особистості Тут я
знайшов свою другу сім'ю моїх друзів
станців з якими я знайомий з самого
дитинства у нашого міста був досвід
окупації це було складнувато коли це
закінчилося аж дихати одразу стало
легше за останні два роки ми зробили
величезну справу Ми зняли чотири кліпи
до яких додали посилання на банківські
картки зібрали дуже багато коштів для
наших ЗСУ і снастили їх всім самим
необхідним для мене дуже важливо що моя
справа життя може приносити користь
іншим а ще не з'являється якесь тепло на
душі коли розуміє що завдяки твоєму
таланту інші також отримують
користь Я дуже гордий те що я за те що я
українець дуже гордий за те що я живу в
цій країні і дуже гордий за те що в мене
є
можливість прославляти нашу неньку дуже
сподіваюся що в майбутньому всі
дізнаються про нашу Україну завдяки
спортивним бальним
[музика]
танцям
Y